since a little bit I'm gonna try to keep
it pretty basic and then maybe at the
end I'll do some hand waving in order to
explain some of Michaels ideas in the
last paper but that would get very
technical so we won't dwell too much on
that it was of course as usual very
beautiful everything that he did okay so
we want to talk about erected appliance
okay but that's not really where this
story begins it begins with undirected
laplacian
so let's first hear about those so
they're defined in terms of a graph G
undirected graph with vertices v edges E
and edge weights W W assigns a positive
way to every edge let's say that there
are n vertices M edges okay and then
let's define the adjacency matrix of the
graph I think you all know what it looks
like but let me say it anyway so the
adjacency matrix a lives in are n by M
and it's given by the a IJ entry is just
the weight on edge
IJ or 0 if no edge okay and then we're
dealing with an undirected graph so
we're going to say that this is equal to
WJ I the weight is the same in both
directions so this means that it's a
symmetric matrix now the let's define
another matrix the degree matrix degree
matrix or this is a diagonal matrix it
lives in RN by n as well
agonal and it just has as you can guess
di I the I sin tree is the degree in the
weighted sense of vertex I so it's the
sum over J incident let's share an edge
with I the weight of edge IJ okay so
then the laplacian of this undirected
graph is plus ul is just D minus a and
this turns out to be a really useful
matrix and part of why it's useful is
that we're really good at analyzing it
so Spielman and tang showed in 2004 that
you can solve equations l x equals B so
that is given L and B we want to find X
you can solve this it's a high accuracy
in time o tilde M and it works with high
probability so we get an approximate
solution X but it's actually it's very
highly accurate though and we get it
really quickly in nearly linear time it
works with high probability is this
useful it's very useful it's had lots of
applications I don't really have time to
write them all out because I don't write
that fast but it's things like computing
electrical flows that's the very
classical application at least in
theoretical computer science or
analyzing random walks in undirected
graphs let me write that so
so this was just one example analyzing
random box in undirected graphs okay and
they also get used for things like
computing maximum flows really good
things to be able to solve linear
equations in okay so that's been a
really big topic in theoretical computer
science now let's talk about directed
laplacian and why they might be
interesting so directed laplacian is
defined in terms of a digraph G so
directed graph still with vertices v
edges which are now directed and edge
weights and it's a positive weight for
every edge still and vertices M edges
and adjacency matrix and then we say
that we have this a IJ is the weight on
edge
IJ but now we don't require that it's
symmetric anyway so it's not a symmetric
matrix the adjacency matrix we still
define a degree matrix but let me now
emphasize that it's the out degree
matrix so it's the matrix of out degrees
so di I we want to sum over J such that
there is an edge 2j from I and then we
get the weight here wait
- J from I okay another way of saying
that is that I is equal to the ice entry
of one transpose a so we look at the
column sum that's the degree the out
degree and then we still define now the
directed laplacian which is d minus a
okay we get fast source the answer is
yes
we get the same thing this is due to
michael john Kellner myself
people's ping Sid furred and Rao and
it's not published yet but should be on
archive soon so we get a solver that
runs in nearly linear time its high
accuracy and it works with high
probability it's the same kind of thing
but the main thing that we know to use
it for is that it's good for analyzing
directed random walks so now we get
things like we can compute the stable
distribution of a random walk in nearly
linear time in the number of entries of
the matrix until Michael got involved
and started working on this the running
time was just empower Omega Omega being
the matrix multiplication constant which
is about two point three seven okay but
then in a sequence of works it got down
to nearly linear so big improvement
problem that had been open for a very
long time but this is just you know the
latest thing really most of the work was
done in earlier things that did not
involve me so Michael kelmer Peng
people's said furred and Vlad who in
2016
gave the first really kind of
breakthrough progress on this they
showed an algorithm for the same problem
and the time was so against solving
linear equations in directed Laplace
since the time was empower 4/3 M plus M
power tooth no sorry M times M power 2/3
okay and then later the same group plus
a new brow also in 2016 they got the
running time down to what's called
almost linear not nearly linear but
almost linear so this is tilde this
should also have a children M X order
square root log
okay this X square root log M grows
slower than any polynomial so it's
better than M power 1 plus epsilon for
any epsilon but it's worse than M poly
log n for any poly log okay and then it
eventually got down to poly log over
here now the key idea up here was to
reduce solving directed laplacian so
linear equations in these two solving a
few so we need a few more systems a few
oily Rhian laplacian switch are a
special kind of directed laplace ian's
but easier to work with so we change it
to a different kind of linear system
which I'll tell you much more about but
then we need to solve a few of these ok
but these are Larry and Laplace seems
we'll get familiar with them and we'll
see that they behave in like undirected
Laplace Ian's in certain ways which
turned out to be very useful ok so that
was the key step here reduce it to a
much nicer case the key step here while
there were really two key ideas the
first one was to develop sparsa fication
of these oil aryan laplacian x'
specification of illyrian Laplace Ian's
how many people are familiar with sparsa
fication of undirected graphs raise your
hand if okay good good so okay so the
same works for oilier in laplacian if
you get a dense oily Rhian laplacian you
can approximate it with another oily
Rhian laplacian that has n log n edges
okay and in a very useful kind of way
however it doesn't work for general
directed laplacian so it's really
important that we have this reduction to
oily area okay
the second key thing was to then combine
this sparsa fication with the squaring
laplacian solver of Peng Spielman from
2014 I think and this I say combined it
gets very messy there's very complicated
recursions that you really need like
Richard Peng or Michael Cohen for so
later we then kind of got rid of all the
complicated recursion and we sted built
an algorithm based on the approximate
Gaussian this this thing based on the
approximate Gaussian elimination
approach of me and search and search
diva okay so specification of oil layer
in the plans and combine it with some
existing undirected solver but get
really messy stuff and then later
simplify but just doing approximate
Gaussian elimination instead but we
weren't able to get rid of meeting this
global specification of oil layer in
Laplace Ian's which is kind of a big
ugly thing that still left there and
this would be a nice way to clean up the
algorithm to get rid of that ok so we
get the sense that oil layer and Laplace
ian's are important so let's talk more
about them
okay
so for all directed Laplace Ian's say L
we have that one transpose L is 0
transpose okay this is actually very
straightforward to see it's just that it
says if we look at the ith entry of this
vector and this vector it says that di I
is equal oh yeah I'm - the I throw of
this thing is equal to zero but this is
just the out degree and this is just the
out degree so of course they're they're
equal to zero the difference is there
now what is an oily Rhian laplacian okay
it's a directed laplacian L where L 1 is
equal to 0
so if we apply it to the all ones vector
from the other side we also get zero
what does this mean if we look at the
ithe entry it says that di I minus the
ith entry of it a 1 is 0 this is the out
degree still but this is the in degree
of vertex I all this is talk about
weighted degrees ok so this says that
for vertex I the out degree is equal to
the in degree and this has to hold at
every vertex then we have an oil lyrium
laplacian ok now I want to just point
out we started learning about illyrian
Laplace Ian's I want to point out some
nice facts about general Laplace Ian's
back up a little bit general directed
Laplace seems
if L is a directed laplacian so not
necessarily illyrian and X is diagonal
matrix with positive diagonal so just
some positive entries on the diagonal
diagonal matrix then LX is a directed
laplacian okay this is easy to check
just write this is equal to DX minus a X
this is the weighted adjacency matrix of
some graph with a new set of weights and
these are the corresponding waited out
degrees so it still works so any
transformation applied to this side
gives us another directed laplacian now
let's talk about walk matrices how many
people have not seen the transition
matrix of a directed random walk or
would like me to talk in depth you've
all seen it good so I'll be I'll be fast
if we take we want a random process on
vertices of a directed graph what we're
going to do is we're going to start at
some vertex then we're going to move to
a random neighbor according to these
edge weights okay so what are the we say
pick another neighbor with probability
proportional to the weight of the edge
going out of of this vertex the
transition probabilities are just a
times D inverse meaning that the
probability of going from I vertex I to
vertex J is the entry W J I okay but now
let's write
but notice that this has a nice
connection to directed apply Siam's
because LT inverse in general for any
directed pass in L is another directed
laplacian by this fact with D inverse as
our X okay but this is equal to I minus
W so I was able to get something that
looks like identity which I think of as
a nice matrix and W which is a nice
matrix to and related to directed
Laplace X okay this is great because now
we can ask all the people who thought a
lot about random walk matrices and perón
Frobenius is a cool theorem in this area
one way of stating it says that if W is
the walk matrix of a random walk in a
strongly connected a directed graph
digraph then the magnitude of every
eigenvalue of W is at most one okay so
the eigenvalues can now be complex
numbers but they are at most one in
magnitude and W has exactly one
eigenvector which I'll call pi
and when I say exactly one I mean up to
scaling by a number of course with W hi
know let me see with eigenvalue 1 so
there's exactly one eigenvector with
eigenvalue 1
a-and hai has positive entries provided
we choose the scale incorrectly ok so
there's only one and it has all positive
entries this is great now that's the end
of her own Frobenius let's note that if
we scale high such that sum over I PI I
is equal to 1 then we can think of this
as because they're all positive numbers
as a probability distribution on the
vertices of the graph and now this
equation w pi equals PI tells us that pi
is the stable distribution of the random
walk what does this mean it means that
if we start with this random
distribution of vertices then pick a
random vertex according to the random
walk distribution then we get a new
distribution on random vertices it's the
same one as we started with that's a
stable distribution so we found it and
we got told by Peron for Venus that
there's only one now notice that I'm
minus W pi is equal to 0 so pi is in the
kernel of I minus W which was a directed
laplacian also it has to be the only
vector up to scalings in the kernel
because if we had any other vector then
we'd get another thing with eigenvalue 1
with respect to w and we know that there
aren't other ones by perón Frobenius ok
now let's write a diagonal matrix big Pi
which is equal to just what we get by
putting little PI on the diagonal then
we can write a little pi is equal to big
pi times the all one's vector so then we
can rewrite this equation as I'm minus W
big pie or once vector is equal to zero
okay but I might as W big pi i minus w
is a directed laplacian so I minus W
times big pie is another directed
laplacian by this fact okay so let me
write this is L tilde and L tilde 1 is 0
so what I've told you is that L tilde is
an oily Rhian laplacian so there's
always a scaling that achieves this and
let us also just note
that L the inverse pi is equal to I
minus W pi
so there's also scaling D inverse PI
that makes the original thing L or
lyrium okay so we can always transform
by a diagonal scaling into having an
oilier in laplace e and well that sounds
good or maybe it's not so good because
if I want to find X that solves this
it's look it looks as hard as solving a
linear equation
right so I'm trying to find X such that
I minus W X is equal to zero but it
turns out and this was the really clever
point of the first paper in the sequence
that we can reduce the problem of
finding this scaling at least
approximately to solving a sequence of
oil erie and laplacian linear equations
in slightly different matrices so we get
it like a sequence of solves in these
slightly different matrices but each
time we're guaranteed that they are a
lyrium so we compile it to the sequence
of easier problems okay well still have
a few minutes at least if I get to do
the counting okay so now I just want to
start hand waving a bit so let me do a
little pull I'm trying to figure out you
know at what level to talk about stuff
that Michael did for example so how many
people have heard of sure complements oh
it's it's the majority so we're gonna
we're gonna talk a little bit about
short complements so he's shaking his
head
okay okay yeah so that's true that's
true but yeah it's gonna be a conflict I
guess we'll start with something simpler
yeah so what does eliminate a vertex
mean it means you've all seen Gaussian
elimination at some point in in high
school maybe or college Gaussian
elimination eliminates a variable in a
matrix and then a variable in the like
remaining matrix and so on and you
repeat when you're dealing with
laplacian matrices you can think of it
as also doing operations deleting a
vertex from a graph and then getting
some graph on the remaining vertices
okay and what is this operation in
directed laplace sense let's talk about
it so when I do Gaussian elimination
what happens to the directed graphs
let's say I want to eliminate a variable
which corresponds to a vertex the one in
the middle it has a bunch of incoming
edges and a bunch of outgoing edges now
I do Gaussian elimination I get rid of
this variable and magically what I have
left the remaining matrix is still an
oilier in laplacian of the remaining
vertices so what does it look like it
replaces this thing with instead of by
clique
where we get an edge from everyone who
had an incoming edge to this vertex we
eliminated to everyone who had and who
is being targeted by the vertex we
eliminated okay so we get this by clique
this is dense so we're in trouble we can
end up making a very dense graph this
way very quickly so how do we make
Gaussian elimination fast we spar safai
this on the fly so we never write down
this by clique we write down a sparse
approximation of it this turns out to be
quite challenging for directed laplacian
because in order to ensure that the
output is always oily Riaan okay the
sparse approximation that we plug in
must preserve exactly the degree of
every vertex well it turns out that we
can do that and we can do it efficiently
and so we preserve the degree
efficiently we also get the property
that if we average over random outputs
we're going to have a randomized way of
choosing the sparse approximation it's
actually an unbiased estimator of this
by clique that we want it so we get
unbiased estimator sparse approximation
now we can try to say okay if it's
unbiased and it's sparse and we repeat
it many times the errors don't add up
too much and we get Gaussian elimination
except not done at all of course because
this only gives us an approximate
inverse then we need to plug it together
with an iterative solver to get high
accuracy solutions and we don't really
have time to talk about that but let me
just you know try to convince you that
there's probably interesting things here
that you should learn about okay so if I
want to approximate things I need ways
of measuring error okay normally I would
measure the error like this
okay I'll keep it to one minute I'd look
and that's not that chance but whatever
[Music]
okay
so we look at this norm squared between
some vector that we we have
approximately that we've found and the
true thing that we want okay
and we do it in some L norm this is the
laplacian this is how we would normally
measure air for undirected laplacian
okay but we don't have a PSD matrix so
what are we going to do we still need an
ocean of air we're just gonna keep doing
the same thing so we're gonna plug in
our oil Irian laplacian here it's not
even clear that this is the norm but
let's write it out let's just look at
the norm of a vector X with respect to
our oil layer in laplacian and this will
be the last thing don't worry it's
defined if I take the as square root X
transpose L X that's just the definition
okay but X transpose LX can't tell that
this is a an asymmetric matrix
it's the same as doing X transpose to
the average of L with its transpose so
the quadratic form with the average now
we have a matrix here that's symmetric
is it PSD yes because for an oily Rhian
laplacian when you average it with its
transpose you get an undirected
laplacian so this is a valid norm and
this is the beginning of a very kind of
exciting subject of doing pretending
that directed laplacian are positive
semi definite matrices which gets
complicated but it's very beautiful and
Michael had very clean but crazy things
to say about it so ask me afterwards
thank you
one quick question so can you give us a
preview of one of the crazy ideas with
Michael okay so one of the crazy ideas
is that this is the arithmetic average
of L with its transpose let's do another
average the harmonic average okay so
let's look at L inverse plus L inverse
transpose average the two and invert
it's the harmonic symmetrization now we
all know that when you look at the
harmonic mean of something it's less
than the arithmetic mean right so the
same is true for matrices no the
opposite is true for matrices okay so if
this thing we try to call ul the
arithmetic mean if we write that and we
call this HL the harmonic mean then u L
is PSD less than HL and that's just the
beginning okay good so this interesting
because Michael was always on the
crusade to kill any crazy I guess
[Laughter]
[Applause]